[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
just yesterday chappelle's show got
cancelled yep
in minneapolis yep and something
happened where these people decided that
chappelle is problematic or transphobic
or what have you and so the venue at the
last minute like a couple of hours
before the show
canceled his performance yeah and he had
to move it to the varsity theater yeah
and uh there's protests and trans
activists protesting outside of sold out
chappelle show in minneapolis so let's
play it hear what they have to say
today is monday july 25th and pale hairy
[ __ ] are still obsessed with dave
chappelle welcome back to the joke world
comedy update every single monday bring
you the news that you need to know in
the comedy world whether it be new
specials new guest appearances on
podcasts or anything happening with your
favorite comedians you can find it all
here on joke world's youtube channel so
please consider subscribing to joke
world right now and downloading this
episode on spotify to support the show
so like joe rogan and andrew schultz
were talking about last week on the joe
rogan experience basically dave
chappelle had a show in minneapolis last
week sold out show at the first av
theater and there were a few protesters
outside the show and it ended up being
cancelled and moved to a different
theater across the street and one thing
that's really funny about this i think
is getting overlooked is that the
theater that canceled the original show
the first half theater released an
apology afterwards
not to dave chappelle but to the
protesters this is what they said we
know we must hold ourselves to the
highest standards and we know we let you
down
we are not just a black box with people
in it and we understand that the first
ave is not just a room but meaningful
beyond our walls
first of all
calm down for zab theater you are just a
room you literally are a black box with
seats in it that people go to watch
shows
let's get that out of the way also that
is insane that they apologized to the
protesters for booking dave chappelle
and their reasoning was they have to
hold themselves to the highest standards
as if dave chappelle is not one of the
greatest public speakers not only of our
generation of maybe human history but
they have to hold themselves to a higher
standard at the first half theater
because it's more than just a room with
black walls
who else is alive that they could book
that's a higher standard than dave
chappelle what a like what it
whatever and this whole dave chappelle
versus angry mob story is kind of worn
out for me i'm sick of it i'm over it
the same thing happens every single time
he releases a special millions of people
love it they get joy and happiness and
laughter out of it and then a few
hundred people get super angry and cry
and [ __ ] and moan and they make all
this big stink and then everyone who
doesn't know and doesn't watch a special
they start piling on just to join in the
movement and the special gets bigger
more people want to go watch it dave
chappelle gets bigger he sells more
tickets then he goes and sells out a
theater 25 dorks show up with their
signs bullying people for going to the
show it makes big news dave chappelle
gets bigger it's the same thing every
single time i mean i wish they would
just kiss and make up they're so stupid
these protesters the anti-dave chappelle
people are so dumb that they don't even
realize every single thing that they've
done so far has escalated dave chappelle
you said one of your buddies was there
yeah one of my buddies went so they
moved it to this other theater and then
the protesters went to the other venue
and were kind of like
i don't know for lack of a better term
like harassing the people that were
going to go to the actual show and my
buddy went there
and they were trying to fight him
oh my god a lot of hostility out here
but it's not a lot of people that are
hostile it's a small amount
it seems like there's like if you're
watching this it seems like there's
probably like 12 or 4 well i don't know
it's hard to see the
who knows yeah but the thing about
chappelle's special that drives me crazy
is that people don't know the full story
and they protest and they get crazy and
they have a narrative that they've
either read or they've seen and they
just adopt that narrative and they run
with it and the narrative is that his
special was transphobic right that
special is not transphobic at all it's
essentially a love letter to a friend
who committed suicide i also just want
to say you are a loser if you're going
to protest people and heckle people that
are going to a comedy show just because
they're happy and have fun and have
things to do in their life and their
brains are developed enough to be able
to take a joke and not get furious and
and melt you're a loser you're a dork if
you go protest someone for going into a
comedy show
but also dave chappelle made a surprise
appearance at madison square garden on
saturday after all this happened he
joined chris rock and kevin hart on
stage he snuck onto the stage and told
them the audience had to sneak my way in
here and despite what you may have read
about me in the news i'm okay and i
appreciate the support so dave chappelle
lives on i'll see you in another few
months when this story completely
recycles itself and the same thing
happens netflix came out with a new
video last week called the hall in which
george carlin joan rivers robin williams
and richard pryor are introduced into a
comedy hall of fame
what is a comedy hall of fame you might
be asking yourself that's a good
question apparently this is the first
class of comedians to be introduced into
the comedy hall of fame which is located
at a place called the national comedy
center in jamestown new york
so they're opening up this comedy hall
of fame at this comedy center that was
built in 2018 and the class of 2022 is
joan rivers robin williams richard pryor
and george carlin who all four are dead
i don't know if that's a requirement it
seems a little strange to have a hall of
fame for something that's so subjective
like is sketch comedy gonna be part of
it is it just stand up is it comedy
movies
like what are the rules to this do you
have to be dead like actually who gets
to vote according to pete davidson who
opened this show nominees for the hall
of fame were voted on by a board of
agents board members club owners and
influential members of the comedy
community
so
that doesn't answer any of our questions
i will say regardless of what you might
think about the starting of this comedy
hall of fame the video itself is
definitely worth the watch each hall of
famer was introduced by a modern
comedian a modern legend basically so
the presenters were jon stewart john
mullaney chelsea handler and dave
chappelle and then after their
presentation that you know they say some
words about each inductee then there's a
montage of some of the funniest moments
from their stand-up from their careers
and it's just i had a good time watching
the montages i learned a few things
about these guys careers and i had a
good time watching the presentations too
being a comedian is not a psychiatric
condition
are many of us also very [ __ ] up
myself included
yes but
whatever you know there are depressed
people who don't even have the decency
to be great comedians
why don't you pick on them for a change
jeff ross also did an in memoriam
section featuring bob saget louis
armstrong norm mcdonald and gilbert
godfried that was also good too he said
those are all for future hall of famers
so now it's just like well why didn't
you just wait to honor them when they're
inducted if this is gonna be an ongoing
thing i don't even know you know what is
fishy about the whole thing is it was
filmed during the netflix as a joke
festival which is when everything that's
been out on netflix that they've put out
every stand-up comedian related thing
that netflix has put out in the last
since they filmed this in may has been
just recycled stuff they filmed at the
netflix as a joke festival so is this
gonna be an ongoing thing is there a
comedy hall of fame now i don't know
i guess we'll see but congrats to the
four nominees the guest list is where we
go through comedian's appearances on
podcast last week to make sure you don't
miss any of your favorites so to start
off your mom's house head on andrew
schultz the joe rogan experience also
had on andrew schultz
along with the tim dillon show good for
you pardon my take kfc radio bffs no
jumper and bad friends we haven't spoken
since since what since your whole thing
since you're free
because you know because she is the
niece
she doesn't give a [ __ ] so we got it we
gotta are you a spy yeah she's around
she's a [ __ ]
but what's wrong with you you keep
inviting a behind enemy line i know dude
get her out of here no i know i was
thinking maybe she shouldn't be here but
don't think dude i know but the thing is
she has 15 years to get out of that
relationship i know i know yeah but you
know what this is this is his tactic
what is it he keeps the enemies close so
so he can
lose you don't know his plan
he doesn't want to lose some he wants to
lose by the way
so korean yeah just keep them up north
like
our neighbors whiskey ginger hat on
caitlyn olsen who plays sweet d and
always sunny that was a great episode
joke world our podcast we interviewed
faheem anwar last week bobby lee was on
the honeydew with ryan sickler they
talked about the breakup things moving
forward some inside details there this
past weekend had on nicki glazer tiger
belly was just bobby lee no kalila
talking with joe derosa and two bears
one cave was burton tom tom and bert
stand up specials that came out last
week you had andrew schultz break the
internet dude he went on every podcast
he had the rock tweeting about it every
celebrity watching his pay-per-view show
he said he made three times the money so
far but you can still buy that special
on his website right now so go check it
out if you haven't it's awesome it's
worth it you still have billboard live
at the red rocks on netflix and the hall
which we talked about honoring the
comedy hall of famers that's it for this
week's joke world comedy update i'll see
you again next monday with some more
comedy news in the meantime please
subscribe like this video turn on the
post notifications all that stupid
youtube [ __ ] that everyone asks you to
do just do it this time man it would
mean a lot
please do it
[Music]
you